in the 1970s the concept of game theory
was all the rage
and there were you know there were
discussions happening all over the place
and if you've ever heard of the
prisoner's dilemma
you know that was one of the things that
came out of these 1970s
um uh salons where everybody was
discussing um
game theory and dr cars was invited to
partake in one of them and there was
mathematicians and economists and he's a
philosopher and all these other
you know clever people and he was
surprised that the only thing they were
talking about was winning and losing
and he raised the question what about
playing
and it's stuck in his head and he went
home and he's got three kids
and um he has a ping pong table in his
house
and he noticed that when the kids play
pig pung there's always screaming and
yelling
there's always accusations of cheating
and somebody always ends up crying
right but when the kids were doing
something creative like lego or
drawing it would go on for hours and
people would waft in and they'd play for
a while and leave and the players kept
changing but the
the lego would go on all day and he
recognized the value of the
of playing and business is playing
it's a cr it's lego it's crea it's a
creative process it's a it's a it's an
ongoing process of building and changing
and adapting and
adding some color and move things around
and employees come and go and leaders
can come and go and like
every employee could completely change
and the company can still exist
and it's this idea of play and so it's a
completely new way to re
to rethink um uh
how this stuff works